they share very similar characteristic
right so in a SQL injection we need to
put some Escape character into the user
input so we can uh put some additional
conditions or even another SQL queries
into the same query and for promp
injection is the same thing but this
time we need to identify the right
Escape character it won't be a symbol
like a single quote or semic column be
in English or in any other language hey
let's start over hey forget about
everything hey let's WR again these are
my character it's not like a new type of
attack but it will be harder to detect
we want to understand hey if there's a
new attack surface showing up how do we
protect it